i can always too strong for the queen
and bishop so
uh nice power of the bishops there we
should mention
raking we should mention the checkmate
threat is the black queen going into the
corner of the board and okay clever
there from mishra offering a trade of
queens and uh white's rook at the corner
does defend the queen so there's no
checkmate yet
but unfortunately now a couple of ways
to win there weren't there i think so
yeah and uh now you can just put it in
the bank just uh start snapping off the
material i mean look at those bishops i
mean they're just incredible and uh
we're going to see resignations here
i think
prague just too strong when the chips
were down when the clocks were ticking
prague turned it around and uh yeah
heartbreak for mishra but
i mean what a game um it's looked like
it's been exciting for move one
both players throwing everything at the
win
and here we go this is a pin white's
rook near the king is about to fall and
we have a result prague takes it oh and
look at mishra such a champion he just
leaves angry with himself for losing
this uh